witness that there's no god there is no
god worthy of worship
from a juvenile when my clothes had
holes in them
and my afro is picky to the nighties
moschino and versace no laces
so i don't know much about liquor man
yeah but what i know is that the
brothers that i trained with
in south london but half and generated
my blessing most
beautiful brothers i've come across in
my life with that adapt the character
the love that they show to other muslims
when in today's today's time we have
other muslims attacking each other
anyways we're not going to go around
here here's a video of a liquor man
except in islam and i saw this video on
uh bhagavad gita's
instagram uh and i didn't think much of
it but apparently he's a
really famous guy hunter has come to
islam uh he's a boxer
uh but anyways watch this video and this
video of brother junaid
uh two brothers and uh
i testify and bear witness i bear
witness that there is no god there
is no god worthy of worship worthy and
worship but allah
but allah and the prophet muhammad allah
prophet muhammad peace and blessing be
upon him
peace and rescue be upon him he was a
final messenger
was a final messenger that's it
articles of faith so you say
yeah a man to be allah
[Music]
i believe in the books that he sent the
torah the bible
and the quran the final being the quran
yet the originals yeah
yeah and i believe in all the messages i
believe from
adam to moses to prophet muhammad to
jesus
to abraham i believe in all the
messengers yeah yeah and i believe
what a young earthly i believe in the
day of judgement yeah well back to back
then
everything that happens after death
allah there's none worthy of worship
except
allah yeah i love you my brother
and listen you are the brother of
everyone here you understand
that you belong you belong to every
single muslim on the face of the earth